you know what you got riots you got
[ __ ] Co vid you got black lives matter
and you haven't heard a word from the
[ __ ] Scientologists have you not a
[ __ ] peep those [ __ ] and all
those parades are on Hollywood Boulevard
staying out there giving out IQ tests
are you greetings from podcast Ville the
church what's happened now is brought to
you by me undies listen this might not
be the summer you had in mind but you
got to do what you got to do to stay
[ __ ] positive and it starts from the
inside out
having comfortable [ __ ] breathable
tremendous underwear is a good way to
[ __ ] and start I'll tell you what I
don't like wearing shorts and underwear
the shirts go up my ass the underwear go
up my ass yeah it's comfortable it's
cool but I don't [ __ ] like it it's
horrible to be uncomfortable and me
undies is the social opposite of being
uncomfortable
it's Comfort it holds your little
[ __ ] nut sacs like a like a [ __ ]
hand holding your [ __ ] nut sack
listen I call the mailman the underpants
fairy because lucky for him he doesn't
have to look under my [ __ ] pillow go
to me undies and get the world's softest
underwear delivered right to your
[ __ ] door I've been dealing
with me on these for years now my whole
underwear desk is me undies I got colors
patterns and guess what my wife's got
the same [ __ ] calling out I'm gonna
have a [ __ ] we don't mix a match we don't
put on the same colors we ain't into
that but that's how deep me on these
girls that tremendous you also get
savings that are clearly and early
access plus free shipping that's if you
sign up for the undies membership to get
a new berry month and that's exactly how
I would start off with this collection
they're made from micro modular fabric
and it's actually made from trees so do
me a favor
get 15% off your first pair free
shipping and 100% satisfaction
guaranteed right now go to me on these
comm slash Joey
that's me undies
dot-com / Joey they're [ __ ]
comfortable they're beautiful I still
got the one they're reliable they
adorable
listen if anybody's got an [ __ ] and
go blow the [ __ ] said underwears it's
me me undies is still [ __ ] taken in
the back go to me undies calm / Joey
it's [ __ ] June the 15th you've been
doing you already did your 90 day
sentence that's it you're out
you remember all these people I could
never go to jail you just did 90 days
[ __ ] same difference
kick this [ __ ] melee thank you
[Music]
oh sure
Monday morning you halfway there caca
liquors the covert is spreading check
your pants you never know what the guest
today is my main man Rodrigo I don't
even know what his last name is Sanchez
Torres Torres Yemen Rodrigo - what
Torres he's the co-host of what's up
pool podcast and a dear dear friend to
me for over [ __ ] 20 years I mean one
of my most embarrassing nights was him
seeing me I'd [ __ ] met I could bake
this field a Stockton stopped I was a
Louis bland gig Louie bland he just
called me a couple months ago he's back
he's doing benefits this [ __ ] good man
what's going on Rodrigo nothing right
here just getting out of that 90-day
sentence you imagine we would have just
been getting out of jail play it
would've been looking like George
Clooney Ocean's eleven get now with the
tuxedo on what the half of that's time I
never seen nobody got out of jail with
everybody gets out of jail with that
little [ __ ] state-issued [ __ ]
shirt they give you from wool warts and
they give you that little bag where you
will call me to paste and [ __ ] oh yeah
just to get you over hop on the bus and
go home hop on the bus Gus and we need
and they give you a hundred on the way
out that people can't wait to get that
first yardstick did you know that Leon
the web they give you like a hundred and
fourteen dollars yeah that's all you
have that's it but who gives a [ __ ] man
you're a prisoner and you just get not
on the house I love it some currency
right there you just blow it dog that
you get the mom's house on the way to
mom's you stop at the liquor store and
see Louis you play a lotto numbers Oh
over Jack your back I mean obviously I
think like this is easier than jail but
how similar is it like I like like isn't
is it the same mental like place that
your mind has been in jail when your
mind in jail your minds been beat up by
the media your minds been told not to go
out go out you can wear the mask you got
to stay eight feet you got to touch this
you didn't get it no oh guess what now
you don't get it from surfaces no more
oh guess what no you happen to be person
to person transverse or tell that mental
damage do that mental damage you know
it's a truly weird I've been talking to
people lately for they're opening up
their businesses in their town
me that dead losing two or three
employees that the employees told them
right out listen will cancel the
unemployment we're just not ready to
walk into that situated at I was like
you know what I feel the same way the
first time I walked into the weed store
and there was five people
I lost my bodily fluid yeah it's
different if I went deaf it takes a
little by little and I've been making
little steps on acupuncture you know
going to the [ __ ] doctors I wouldn't
did that MRI I finally went back to Nova
Thor I've been taking little steps
everything is written down in case I
start turning purple in the middle of
the [ __ ] night you know who the [ __ ]
I've been because now I gotta do a back
check to see where you've been
you had the tracing you're talking to it
yeah so if I was everybody I keep my
life that simple right now keep your
life simple it is not God if you believe
it or not believe it it doesn't make a
difference to me do I believe it fully I
know there's something else involved but
since I have had friends that have had
sick they've tested positive they've
told me the results some people ended up
in the hospital
some people just had a fever for four
days you know I don't know what it is I
can't afford to get sick especially on
the road like I saw last night well what
have you won that land a Saturday night
they burned down that [ __ ] Wendy's I
mean what I call Lee was crying what's
going on what's going on
black people I don't know what the one
day did yeah yeah chicken sandwiches
nobody was happy for the Wednesday
outside giving spicy chicken sandwiches
all since I light the place up on
[ __ ] fire and I know of Lee was day
be Luton we be going in there getting
those last little square burgers home by
Johnny Wendy by himself in it making
Wendy burgers he was crying when Wendy's
is burning but it's [ __ ] up though
because all those Pete I'm een
you got right still lingering around you
got the cove it's still lingering out
around and everybody that's mentally
[ __ ] you got a couple blowhards out
there I don't give a [ __ ] I'm open to my
business
I'm going back to work I understand sir
each one of those guys you got a
thousand people that are scared their
skin
there's businesses that have gotten the
green light and still have not opened
yeah cuz I noticed a couple weeks ago
they had that restaurant Anneli open for
like sit down and a lot of them are
still just take out just just okay I'm
gonna tell you something people were
rushing to open I've realized one thing
that not that many people coming out now
the real reality is coming in this is
working now that the realities are
coming in that yeah you open now what
you thought they were using were running
with this type of this money there's a
million people in this country live
hand-to-mouth
there's a lot more people living
hand-to-mouth a lot more people [ __ ]
slinging deck
oh hell yeah you know we just don't see
it just will appear in fairytale [ __ ]
Ville but I know for a fact that these
people you know they go hand to mouth
even in fairytale land they go and to
[ __ ] them out
so all these people who thought I'm
gonna get back to work I'm losing money
by the day once you open you ain't gonna
make them much money either if you've
noticed every restaurant you go to you
wait a couple minutes with your food
they don't have to people back there no
more they got one guy if 20 people
decide to eat Chinese on the same day
you waiting 45 [ __ ] minutes somebody
just told me they waited and I don't
want to have for delivery come away so
that happen from a Mexican place you
know it's it is what it is meant and
it's gonna be a new life and you know
look at these stand up still they're
going out right now I would hate it to
being out on a Saturday night no it'd
have been crazy trying to get out Sunday
we don't know what's gonna happen in any
city and any given weekend didn't that
uh did the riots a couple week ago kind
of stunt a little bit of the shows that
were out there like yeah yeah they
[ __ ] you know they canceled showed
you know what the [ __ ] gonna happen I
mean right now is the time we're like
you know you got to sit back and just
look you know you know Gabriel is doing
the right there there's a lot of guys
that just said listen we rescheduled
once they just got a call they pushed it
back you know Gabriel made whatever go
to Forbes you know need to got this run
he'll need to put that stress on himself
there's a lot of guys
need to go out that you think the same
time you don't wanna kind of wiping a
kid maybe for six months how he did not
go to [ __ ] Valley Ford and sell cars
for six months still do comedy locally
still do all the clubs and everything
when it opens up you know but that you
got to injustice right all this is just
a [ __ ] adjustment you're switching
gears right now cuz I know a lot of
people want to be I got to be out there
for the fans are gonna be out there
first for the people that go out there
first if not they're gonna forget about
you so you know that's you know I'm sure
this the backer you know what I'm not
going on guess what
I'm not they're not forgetting about me
and I'm not forgetting about that they
know if they know anything about me at
all 57 years old they know that you know
I have hypertension you can hear it on
my voice that I have the beginnings of
emphysema so whatever you want to think
you could think you know you've got to
go away to be missed you got to go away
to be missed so that's it this should
have shown up in your town every year
and then expecting people to come to
your shows and more you know I don't
expect nothing from nobody my concern to
be honest to you isn't even my sanity to
be honest here it's a little bit of my
safety I don't want to bring nothing
home and I don't want to burden my wife
by getting sick again hit the head with
a brick and [ __ ] sometimes when I go
to because somebody wants to riot that
night my concern is really the audience
I would hate to get a [ __ ] Facebook
from somebody saying hey man I went to
your show last week at The Improv and
three days then I tested positive for
coal pit you know unless you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] now you're retracing your
steps yeah and you're watching where
you're going and you're being a little
bit open-minded you know I'd open-minded
but it's reasonable reasonable there's
19 people in that circle with masks on
one of them's got to have to have he had
it one of them's got to have something
he's I'm saying why go over there hello
how you doing hey where you going I
gotta go pick up the kids and I'm very
some people yes now
to the pump of my daughter sadly I saw
some people having a party you know all
of my face masks on and they do the
social distancing and you know there's
people who can as people don't give a
[ __ ] I respect you too I think if I
didn't have a wife and it can I be a
hypocrite to tell you that I wouldn't
wear deck right you know I would be out
there I'd be in Vegas right now getting
it with that [ __ ] protest and breath
if you're gonna go to a party like that
to Coco it's like [ __ ] once you just do
that party through Zuma what the [ __ ]
I'll tell ya I don't want them done to
resume she's horrible I I tried to move
my friends from high school the other
night just just just for a difference
you know I was like how many nights can
I go to the office and listen to stupid
music my friends are having a zone maybe
this will cheer me up a little bit it's
been 20 years since I seen and half
these guys well first of all my internet
doesn't do well between 5:30 and 7:00
for some reason every night everybody
using it my employment just doesn't do
well it's a little sluggish after dinner
I have my Howard I put my weight
watching points and [ __ ] it doesn't
stick I shut the phone off I gotta find
the [ __ ] whatever so that was it was
stuttering what is it called
lagging lagging and then it just got
lost and I was like you know what once
it lost I was like that's a sign from
God to tap out I was one guy then I was
going one guy and it was just that for
me and zooming is not for me
if you gotta do it you gotta do it ah
yeah I'm my best to wrap around it and
make it interesting but it's not for
[ __ ] me abandoned some of those like
the podcast you got to do it cuz the
distance that's what we're doing on the
what's a full podcast right now but when
[ __ ] go to the length of doing
comedy shows on there that's where just
like you know that shit's gonna last
there forever to listen I wanted to
break I look forward to this break I
didn't know this break was coming
but we needed this brain let's [ __ ]
covet [ __ ] everything what's going on
with you George Inc nothing they had a
[ __ ] kid man and it's all different
we've been in the game a long time
together we go back a long time you won
the first place in the Joey Diaz
impersonation come down he still talks
about he once he's ready for you you
don't have the war he lost the war like
you said it before you Kayden's you came
in with the walk and you but he has the
motion right right right
and the voice the voice but you don't
have to walk you got to show up with the
pigeon toe whole thing if you don't show
up with the pigeon toe - uncle Joey
you [ __ ] up already you gotta show up
with the pigeon toe yeah and then no not
to interrupt you but a lot of people
think that Joey Diaz impression is just
that rough out the pocket but it's not
there's like 17 versions of Coco I mean
you can be a sweetheart cupcake and then
the next thing you know he's hitting you
upside the head with the glass I mean so
it's all that in-between and you know
but you also gotta you know you gotta
love that East Coast New Jersey [ __ ]
all that lingo dog and that's what it's
about if you're into that mafia [ __ ]
like do your representation of that
region of America so it's like you know
if you love all that [ __ ] and like you
know you slick your hair back all the
attitude all that [ __ ] you got to throw
that all in there so some people just go
for that you know [ __ ] slice your
throat Joey but I mean I do the whole
[ __ ] thing with the tennis shoes the
foot the hip the the looks smiles
everything somebody asked me who do you
want to play you and your morning you
better have a pigeon toe but I'm good
you know saying cuz if you don't show up
with that [ __ ] right pigeon town
people pigeon toe the way you want my
opinion foot the way it goes in oh it's
something do my hip to be honest it's
something my hip that's why I keep
[ __ ] this knee up
I find myself driving with my heel with
my fourth pointed right and your legs
are kind of a contradiction so my legs
my hip is kind of weird it just goes to
the side yeah not to sound creeper
nothing I remember on your apartment and
you don't have the way you laid down
with your cats you you know you lay down
a different way then you know some
people you know do the little
yoga thing or just on their stomach and
[ __ ] but you just like you like an
octopus almost ugh and you sitting there
with the cat just or you don't quote
Leon yeah so a guy from West Holly so
did you she's very distinct you know you
swag so you know you got to emulate all
that you're really you're really good at
impressions like where did that start
with you do to start a long time ago due
to started with the movie La Bamba I
used to do a Richie Valens but through
like you know [ __ ] you know the Philip
you know what was his name [ __ ] uh
actor Lou Diamond Phillips yeah and my
mom didn't like that [ __ ] he smacked me
a couple times I don't know why she's
just like don't and then you know doing
impressions of them and doing
impressions of family members but it
didn't start breaking till this guy that
caught me stealing they would come like
basically just said like a little
Mexican store would come to the
neighborhood and it's just like a big
old like not a u-haul truck but just
those big old box truck exactly but had
bunch of shelves had dry goods mostly
candies [ __ ] warm sell everything I
love nothing so uh you know everything
was cash and credit so we'd go up there
and then the guy had a distinct voice he
looked a little way look like a cheap
bass Elvis you know and I do impressions
of him and then that's when they started
laughing I guess it was I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was like stop [ __ ]
around but then people with distinct
voices there was another guy that lived
in the neighborhood right there that he
had a he was kind of gay well he was gay
but he nobody said he was gay and he had
a little voice a little way about him
and then I would do the voice people
just start [ __ ] just dying and then
boy doing impressions of my uncles and
[ __ ] and just people that had a distinct
voice something that you know you notice
everybody would notice about them and
then just copy real quick and if I like
them too because I mean some people like
doing oppression of this fool fool so
yeah I can't really do it but I figure
if you know you kind of like got fall in
love with it
same thing with James Gandolfini that's
what that whole East Coast [ __ ] right
there yeah it's crazy how you know I'm
looking at you there was you and Vinny
and you were kids and you were still
going out every night to see rock bands
ish yeah man [ __ ] vintage do you
remember you guys want to see cake
yeah yeah we took the leap into the mind
we paid the mind so I sent Los Angeles
you know I'm the other day I was taking
you coming on I was in the kitchen doing
something and
thinking about how many [ __ ] nights a
week we're out there like that was it
Monday nights were always at that place
sunset room sunset Rolla and I still
remember looking at the clock and it
being a quarter to and we were still out
there talking [ __ ] eating Donuts like
mine of us they'd be a giant butt joint
going across
laughing you're smoking I did cash this
is Morris podcast couple weeks ago and
he asked me a question about you know
what happens you know I kind of little
jaded with comedy
once it and I got a bunch of emails
about of the you a comment no I didn't
hate comedy I just hated what it became
it was something it was ten years ago
there was nothing going on for none of
us and I'm those nights how happy were
we nobody had nothing going on I had a
movie big deal that's it I really had
one leg thing going on and that was it
and it's all these guys nobody was
getting more money in nobody everybody
was getting $30 $35 a free drink
remember the owner will pull out a food
platter get devourer to the wings the
wings would be [ __ ] raw but you
didn't give a [ __ ] is you a flat broke
they just saved you a buck you have to
stop and [ __ ] taco world and eat you
know just III think back of those nights
and that's what people don't understand
that that's the fun times of Qaumi one
other than Seattle with Josh wolf and
all those dudes you know I want four
guys back in a car and you go on Vader
gig like you don't give a [ __ ] like what
are we doing tonight
Rodrigo's doing a feature over at the
improv who's the headliner such-and-such
all we need is one [ __ ] let's
say [ __ ] him it'll start we just go down
it like what's an airline old-looking go
what's going on we're doing a guest I
will Rodrigo what I was in the forum you
don't need them no nook
the back we get smack when we live in
Seattle we were doing that [ __ ] it was
gangsta comedy there was a gig on
Fridays I never showed up to and she
paid me every week she made me the house
emcee and I was like 25 bucks for a Navy
base I'm not going down there but the
checks kept coming and she would call me
see how's the room going on Fridays
great four or five weeks until see she
called me she's like saying you haven't
been showing up I go yeah I do the time
and leave nice this Pat Wilson wasn't it
good lady she's 25 bucks a week that's a
good lady but it was 25 it wasn't was it
Pat Wilson there was two people who
booked that room there was a gay Cuban
guy who bought the old improv in Seattle
and he now he was booked like The Improv
was closed but the people warmed it
still booked out Friday and Saturday so
he would just get a bunch of $50 comics
just fill it out and just fill it up and
there'd be a hundred people and then it
was right across in a pike peak market
right across right across trying to go
to the corner across the street and
right there was Pikes Peak and if he
crossed that corner and cross the street
it's the strip club 100 ugly ones and
one fat one DejaVu was right yeah right
there right there like it was like the
[ __ ] hottest corner in the world he
had I forget what his name was on Andhra
or some [ __ ] like that
but all those nights is with people you
know many of us out of the nine of us
that were hanging out five of us had to
get up and go to work at 8:00 and you
didn't give a [ __ ] like that's how much
you loved common that you had to be at
work at 8:00 but it's like I'm here with
Martin Felipe Joey
Edwin you know there was like nine of us
rolling deep you know I can't imagine oh
hey George Perez George Perez this is
2010 2008 2009
there's 11 years ago I mean I met when I
met you I was still doing drugs so you
think I made in 2001 yeah that's 19
years ago I was deep in it that's how I
was wearing the fat wasn't even that big
da da
Big Daddy da or Big D Big Daddy but you
have the da da shoes you were endorsed
by and they gave you a bunch of clothes
I'd only reason why I had da big dog
Donna was because that's what they sold
that [ __ ] marshals I thought you were
getting heard uh no okay every Friday
when they get like my forty five dollar
check from the commie stuff I go over to
labret and the sunset what's that
Marshalls mmm and that's what they had
so if you or 3x or above you got da da
like a [ __ ] you got
blacklivesmatter shirts you know for the
Big D those big diabetes brothers that's
what you got left over whatever sure
said I'll use the diabetes clinic with a
big diabetes father's the brothers from
whatever those gonna grab the Fat Boys
so that's where the diabetes brothers
send that clothes to Marshalls so I was
going on a [ __ ] Friday night bust out
a little warm-up suit for 30 I was in
there switching tags then I was putting
green dots on them put a green hanging
around the thing I just switched the
suit and prop it up or down
look at me get it for ten bucks like it
was ridiculous what I was doing in those
days they weren't ready for me was a
headshot store back in the day there was
a little corner of Marshall it's long
died there's more Asian guy that had a
headshot store so I would order the
headshots on Tuesday and he tell me come
by Friday Friday come back I go get a
sweater
Dada swellow a diabetic sweater and
they're like the one to get my headshots
for the week and there was something out
there was a 7-eleven it's still there by
Marshalls and all that shit's still
there they got like a Hawaiian food I
haven't been in that mall in 12 or 13
more leads to be a blockbuster that
right there on the corner buster yeah
the only thing that's new in there they
got a Starbucks in there now yeah but
that's crazy Ford Regal that you and I
go back that long and then we were
rockin and rollin and then 2007 when the
stock market crashed oh hey that's when
we realized that we were rolling all
those rooms shut down yeah there was so
many Mexican rooms the Mexicans I gotta
hand it down to the Mexicans bro and I
thank them a lot all of them from
Sebastian Cetina - Rudy Moreno they
might not know it you know they really
made like it was like a double training
I was getting Comedy Store training and
combat training it doesn't Mexican rooms
I even got to give props to Ernie G up
at the [ __ ] universal on Monday
night's the rumble the rumble room you
know these are things that you did you
just did you woke up on Monday when wolf
I got a spot the Rumba room that's
number one let's see if the Laugh
Factory calls me back so you'd pop at
8:15 8:35 at the Laugh Factory and then
run up to Universal City Park and then
if you were lucky you got a 12:00 at The
Comedy Store and you shot back down
[ __ ] from Universal Ernie paid you 40
that's tremendous $40 I need five hours
away
put a nickel in the gas tank and really
get the party started
I know you're saying that you miss those
times I get it but like is it
sustainable like if you were still at 57
surviving our 40 dog gigs
would you still enjoy it do you think if
I wasn't doing blow listen some people's
priorities are some people's priorities
I look at it for the pure bottom line
everything has a square root correct
you're on stage you're living in Los
Angeles and you're working at you train
you're not Kevin Hart
who cares you're not Dave Chappelle 8:46
you're not Joe Rogan you're not Marc
Maron you're not doesn't matter you're
still in the [ __ ] game and your dream
is still alive okay
so I'd say this pandemic came along and
took the wind out of your sails and you
can pay rent for a few months and you go
to but back to Boston or back that land
or back to Philadelphia or back to
Mexico does that make you less of a
comic no you're still a comic you just
have to adjust to your surroundings now
so how am I gonna make it as a local
comic oh [ __ ] look at that barnacle they
do a sports night on Wednesday Michael
talk to you gotta go back to the basic
oh you go back to the basics yo what's
good man you have three clubs she gotta
find one of the three clubs listen I'm a
headliner you and I both know it you saw
me in The Longest Yard you saw me
whatever what if what if I came in here
four nights a week and proceeded for you
and I promised to just do no material
I'm not here to destroy the feature but
at least you have you give your show
some you know I like to work with the
open mike rizzo that that you know all
[ __ ] like that that all adapt
you gotta adapt go to your radio station
how you doing
my name is Joey Diaz I'm not looking for
money I'm gonna come in as an intern you
join tears from the movie yeah why do
you want to come in as an intern cuz I
can't go on the road I got nothing else
going on I moved back to be close to my
[ __ ] dead uncle I love them blah blah
blah you know whatever your situation is
you're always gonna be a comic you move
to the Philippines you cutting pigeon
heads off in the daytime but at night
you're doing comedy in between o'clock
and karaoke people will figure it out if
you really love doing what you're doing
you figure it out let's say you come out
here you've exhausted all your avenues
and now you move back to wherever the
[ __ ] you're from and you get a day job
and it may be something that you want
maybe
that you don't like but you just paying
the bills you've cut your rent down low
you're back home you know whoever the
[ __ ] you're from the rents are low
somewhere though IO or Milwaukee I don't
know where you're from you know you call
me is great at that level because you're
gonna get top dollar at night so you're
gonna make a couple hundred a week extra
and get your day job it never ends you
never stop being a comic you don't quit
comedy because you didn't get a TV show
that means you didn't love it you didn't
love it from day one you gotta love this
you gotta love that part of it yes I
love getting a nice chat over on the
road for a weekend but I'm telling you
Rodrigo if I knew what I knew now I keep
it to that level get a tremendous day
job where I made great money I kinda
have to go in till 11:00 and like a do
all that [ __ ] yeah there's [ __ ]
there doing that [ __ ] now they do it now
when I've lived in Denver there was a
dude who was an attorney one of the
funniest [ __ ] black dude you ever saw
in your life you couldn't get this guy
on the road people begged this guy to go
on the road his day job paid so much and
his wife loved him so much and his kids
he couldn't go on the road well he would
be busted he would come out and throw 20
minutes he give him a breather and then
he go
you white [ __ ] like
impersonations and it'd be in bed when
they go yeah he's all right give me a
minute let me prepare a turnaround and
you'd see him do something and he turned
back around his vito corleone II black
dude same haircut like Vito and the
Godfather and he come on go this is my
impersonation of the Godfather you ready
and he come on and go the dentist [ __ ]
up my Pete and he would hold his face
maybe just like meet up because my I
mean he would just torment him I still
remember his jokes
he was like I was still watching this
guy's great and I asked me what's the
problem with this guy I mean he would
weigh a ton allow a suit onstage like
Armani suits and custom-made suit that
always is [ __ ] decked out shoes and I go
why don't you go on the road both take
me on the road with you I wanna learn
these like five fat I'm not sleeping I'm
no [ __ ] a hotel bed you know you
learn from those guys you team up with
those guys I don't think just because
there's guys in little small pockets
I've said this a million times it was
podcast of the 20th times funnier than I
am they just never want to come to LA
somewhere long ago I've seen it I got
crossed I've seen it like you've seen it
I've seen it I don't know if you know
who this guy is Frank Dale Pizzo an
older man he's been around forever
and then he was working the club that we
were to go it's that captain Brian's the
other club he had before he had off the
hook and uh he's all yeah guys whatever
guys if I get a given I'm gonna get
Delphine the impression cuz he's Italian
this [ __ ] he's all loving it and then
he's off at the and then a sleepers all
his hits him up he's all you want to do
a spot he's all I hosted [ __ ]
and we're just like yeah you know you
don't think give me he's like it looks
like a dad kind of you mean the Gulf sin
[ __ ]
that [ __ ] went up there and
hosted dude and he destroyed the [ __ ]
world he destroyed the [ __ ] quit
tomorrow and into a little suburb and
just want a little bee room on Fridays
and Saturday with no care in the world
no industry I've already got a little
milk I will light up features I will
have feature acts Quinton I will have
they'll be the strong to surge of
feature acts you've ever seen in your
life because after four days of
following me at that level you
definitely improve as a feature five day
five shirts and five shows and you gotta
just with no cares in the world
ten minutes oh sure so you're not gonna
do nothing tell me that small town and
in the end I'll do nothin to me then I
move to but Duke the Kentucky willing I
didn't me shoot me I'm gonna go up then
just lay it out for 10 minutes that
feature is gonna be knocking on his
boots
because I know I would at that's at that
level for years oh you're still knocking
on your boots
you still get thrown out as they go
coming to the stage and SWAT this
[ __ ] is cracked when he told me
the story I already know I'm a comic I
know how to crack a comic right before
they go onstage that's the easiest thing
for bill but I can't be doing that [ __ ]
to me because then people start doing it
to you so you gotta be careful when you
crack a comedian before he goes onstage
see you in Seattle we went out to crack
comedians that's not a good business
because sometimes you had them crack
them so hard you crack yourself you piss
on their leg so bad you end up pissing
on yourself you said so many disgusting
things to that person that it goes into
your psyche now and now you ruin your
set so you put the Maluku on yourself so
this poor kids in the back dying because
he's bombed and he can't figure out why
he bombed he doesn't know that you put
them a Luke on them
did you see the riots last night did you
know you said you see how they kill that
black man ain't nothing on his neck and
you get them all fired up and they go up
you know I got a black comic now I might
as you listen I'm at a show right now
CBS is there the decide about six guys
for a TV show the guy in front that says
if it's this week right now the guy in
front of me is african-american he's
done I don't give a [ __ ] if he's Dave
Chappelle I'll crack him ten minutes
before I just get next to him and start
hitting them with the race riots
you know Frederick Douglas I start
dropping [ __ ] Martin Luther King I
shower BB guns I tell him you know NAT
Turner's yeah yeah you know I turn this
[ __ ] you know I'll just say [ __ ]
to him that'll make him think and throw
him off his game now is that a nice
thing to do to people no it's not that's
a thing you use in cavalry competitions
and
and you gotta carry competitions it's
the same as baseball - same as
basketball man we all watched the last
dance yeah Jordan was coming to town
they adjusted for Jordan so let's say
it's me you Lee
Eric Rocha Steve Simone D'Agostino
walnut contest and Philippe me you and
we get together D'Agostino boy listen I
don't know what's gonna happen here but
we're not letting Philippe what we're
gonna do everything in our world well
why this dressing room on fire it's
gonna be one disaster I'm alone if they
order a sandwich you wanna put a rock on
his sandwich so he bites it with his two
chips we're gonna push him right over
the [ __ ] top we're gonna put [ __ ]
itchy powder in the shoes we're gonna do
everything he can the hotel is act is
getting three [ __ ] bomb alerts the
middle of night we gotta leave the hotel
and come back in fuckabish late yeah
that that's what you do we're gonna
refuse him from doing well and then we
got it up on ourselves now hold the [ __ ]
do you think I learned that from that
move I did that move as a comic but then
it got reinstated into my head when I
met James Coburn when I did Arliss and I
met James Cole but that's my idol that's
one of my big idols if you go to Cuba
and you mentioned James Coburn I like
what Steve McQueen all that [ __ ] you
know I did two days on a set with James
Coburn the second day is all about Bruce
Lee I kept it very light I didn't say
nothing until he started talking to me
in between tanks and then we were just
talking and then I told my had we there
was a different story
me him Alice Stevens but just when I was
supposed to join Here I am smoking a
joint with James Coburn arthritic hands
like Ed Wood yeah you know and he said
that to me knows the best movies ever
made was the Magnificent Seven because
we tortured your brother they couldn't
stand your brother because he had just
played that part
you know the famous your brother part he
played I told the story thousand times
on here he played a big part I don't
want to rape okay I don't know if
Lawrence of Arabia so they were telling
me how they would torture is hating on
him hating on him because they refused
Charles Bronson and Steve McQueen will I
listen ain't no [ __ ] haribol gonna
come and hear the [ __ ] up our movie
that's not yeah she's not gonna watch so
it was America to the core but it was so
funny cuz I was just thinking about this
because they said the formosa is open
again he was on Twitter the day Friday
at the Formosa and the stories he was
telling me we're about were from the
Formosa they'd be shooting a movie and
they would put him up around the Warner
Brothers lot close the Formosa walking
this they were all lured to her for loss
and he's like telling her he was me
Charles Bronson George see Scott Gene
Hackman
in hands and pound so he's there and
he's we all decided that [ __ ] it take
him out of the movie every night they
would call you Brenda's hotel room [ __ ]
you and hang up on amis [ __ ] knock on
his door and [ __ ] gonna pull the fire
alarm just all the [ __ ] they did to
knock your Brenner off his game but if
you're doing that then you're too busy
cuz you're tired yeah man you're
thinking too it's taking energy to do
that [ __ ] and the more evil that [ __ ] is
the more energy it takes its power bro
so that's a different side to calmly man
it's good to see you Rodrigo Oh likewise
you just [ __ ] in the corona really
[ __ ] up just seeing your friends yeah
look at [ __ ] child I love when people
call me they want to hang on hang on man
I see at the store give me hug no pork
in the back real quick because people
gotta come up to us and interrupt this
so we can't get into nothing deep like
what a green room yeah and you don't
really get to see people and I thought I
wasn't seeing people before with the
store now you see nobody again has been
a really
[ __ ] tough 90 day so I'm happy you
guys in the church have really kept it
together I hope you all have I've read
some post I've lent out my support on
the Facebook pages you know we've all
gone through a rough times during this
[ __ ] man this has been prison without
prison yeah and what's key is what you
said earlier you know you have to adapt
whatever you whatever it is you do
comedian or otherwise if he had another
hustle I mean [ __ ] cuz I was like I was
like I didn't need to make any more
money I mean my wife works but I mean
you feel like a [ __ ] loser - you
can't be just sitting and scratching
your balls and holding a baby all day so
uh and I used to do pest control but I
had all my [ __ ] you know so I just
[ __ ] put out on a podcast you guys
need your [ __ ] pad sprayed and a lot
of people were calling me - pincher bugs
are out why guess we had a crazy rain
season so you know spiders and roaches
and ants so I just went to work you know
you know couple jobs a day boom boom and
uh you know you just adjust and that's
just you know for the time being
whatever the [ __ ] happens I know we're
scheduled to go to Houston
July 17th through the 19th the improv
but you know you just gotta you gotta
adapt to the [ __ ] whatever it is
whether it's a [ __ ] pandemic or not a
lot of people you know you know they get
caught up in like Instagram and what the
what they're supposed to be doing it's
just like you know you got to go back to
the basics and you know do you you know
I I learned that the news was destroying
me I learned that media coverage was
destroying me so I tried to keep the
internet down as much as I could thank
God I got this thing I gotta have this
outline by July 14th guys thank God it's
kept me straight it's painful to dip
into your past especially during a
[ __ ] pandemic cuz you go a little
deeper cuz you got more time to think
about it cuz I tell ya see low a little
deeper so the past has been haunting me
throughout this like I've said anibal's
and it opened us into some paths or yeah
it did some wrongdoings I had done past
and it's so weird that I made up good
with some people and some people was
just they would never understand an
apology you know like there's people
that I've tried to make
menswear yeah and those people exist as
well you know somebody giving
forgiveness and then you know somebody
not wanting to take it you know and
there's some you know no matter what you
can't crack them yes people though I
cannot I don't expect them to forgive me
I wouldn't forgive me and it was
something simple like it was just
something simple like I was thinking
about all the people that from that era
there's a handful of people that I truly
missed that we just don't talk and you
know why we don't talk it's been 20
years like this one couple that I love
dearly I dealt with both of them on a
business level I was friends with her
and I was friends with him since we were
kids and we haven't said a word to each
other since 1995 and you want me to tell
what it was over a hundred bucks and a
misunderstanding a hundred bothers this
is two people grew up together who made
more than 100 bucks together we were in
business together a couple [ __ ]
things but that's all it took it wasn't
about the hundred bucks it was a bum
misunderstanding of payment and both of
us don't talk to each other and a couple
years ago I gotta be honest she as she
reached out maybe Facebook seven years
ago I was still little so I have that
hand and mercy yet I was still a little
sour and now I went looking for her and
I can't find the page so she's probably
off there you know it's just really
weird with this endemic has done but who
gives a [ __ ] where's the Scientologists
there's the Scientologists have instead
of [ __ ] water
they're in their bunker guys won't broke
Humpy's is alive and that's all they
give a [ __ ] about not a people the
scientist who's ever running Scientology
shame on you like I said last week Isis
wears ice has been perfect time for them
to show up to all these protests and
pull up in go Baba Baba hummus in here
how cutely idea not not one Isis doing
this out there amazing how they just
disappear cuz the corona virus even Isis
is scared
I didn't really think they're gonna
close all the [ __ ] down and it started
happening I was like God Danielle oh
yeah they closed it down you had to
close it down and if you've been to New
York or you live in New York when you're
in that area said sit and think about
what you see every day when you go to
New York and sit and see why that place
became ground zero stance it's people on
top of people you know and then it's a
subway city it's a bus city you'd think
they encourage you not to have a car for
years that's the reason you moved to New
York not to have a [ __ ] car now you're
out there amongst these [ __ ] germs so
I'm good bro now that's all that stuff
is out of me I'm looking forward to
what's coming ahead we've already dug
back into the past now let's see what's
gonna come ahead of us I want to see
what happens the next few months I got
my eye on it very [ __ ] I'm watching
these businesses like I said before that
have opened expecting the gold rush in
nineteen twenty and guess what ain't
nobody coming it ain't nobody coming in
so you know I'm expecting to hear every
day every week you're gonna hear
something oh yeah every weekend I and my
heart goes out to them you can just hold
on as much as you can you could just try
I don't know the [ __ ] business I
don't have a storefront I don't pay
storefront insurance I don't know what
it's like to run a [ __ ] restaurant I
don't know what the health codes are the
health hazards food cost how long it
takes to [ __ ] deliver the food how
long either hold it in your freezer for
you know what if people open look down
last week them had to boil it up again
this has been a nightmare
so expect the sea life change as you
[ __ ] knew it
you're gonna stay the same as uncle Joey
slinging dick smoking reefer and telling
stories on a Monday morning whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do you gotta do that's
it it's Monday morning it's a whole new
[ __ ] week you got a second chance to
start again and that's how I look at it
you know I gotta lift weights today my
gym is open so I get my chick again it's
just me in the house then she's gotta
take out a half-hour break steam clean
the gym then somebody else comes it so
her clientele got cut in half
so all this is is a paid time and it's
an adjustment it's an adjustment and for
right now you adjust you do the best you
can you know peanut butter and jelly
never killed nobody right or wrong
nobody's ever died from peanut butter
and jelly nobody dies from oatmeal
unless you're allergic right
nobody dies some oatmeal nobody's ever
come on TV with a twisted face the
machine is what happened to my throat
meal nobody all right nobody's ever come
on TV and said you know you know I got
heart disease or means peanut butter and
jelly I'm like oh you know now you know
you got allergies you buy that bag of
chicken breast those [ __ ] kick
chickens you can see the dent in their
chest they got kicked like by a [ __ ]
Mexican soccer star they just set him
loose they give them to it they give
them to it's a met on a [ __ ] can of
[ __ ] true-blue what's a [ __ ] Red Bull
Red Bull and they go go and they let
this soccer guy go crazy kicking these
chickens or whatever Tyson [ __ ]
chicken breast the boneless ones they
got a little dental of me like what the
[ __ ] will got yeah well done for this
chest day you got kicked with a steel
toe what are you gonna do
we all suffer man this is it this is
part of it them you know you sit there
and it's [ __ ] 3:00 in the afternoon
and you've done everything you were
supposed to do and then sir
you even dropped off clothes at the
[ __ ] for people's house and then I'll
even open up our lancashire and as
you're pulling around you see [ __ ]
the line at in and out empty if you've
only eaten it out stupids now it's time
to do it just don't boil at 12 six but
two in the morning go to nine eleven
fifteen you think they got AIDS you
ruined a ruined Chinese soup for me
because I before this I didn't want to
believe that they were doing cat and
said chickens but now with the money
being low I'm like if they were ever
gonna do it this would be the time to
have fun
Chinese food yeah there was a caddy
to his side it was hidden under the
broccoli I put it to the side inspected
see like this over there they got good
rats eat still gonna sit he got good
rats they clean they gotta a klutz
they eat over at Whole Foods they're
like vegan they eat hummus you know you
eat a rat in Studio City it ain't that
bad they got gallons and Whole Foods
over here they're not that good it's not
even the rouse they give them lettuce
and [ __ ] it's like they're eat your
shoes or taking pizza pies off the train
like in New York you ever see that brat
that took the peace oh the slice of
Pete's up to train that that dudes
unhealthy but these rats I got here
these [ __ ] get vitamin D
they're in good shape right they don't
die easy these [ __ ] I hang on man I
remember one day I got a call that
Rodrigo fell on his back off a ladder I
should happen in the Hollywood Hills
done and I'm like what do you know what
happened then he shook it off yes that's
so funny that's what that joke came from
shook it off a [ __ ] ladder most white
people would have sued whatever that's
amazing Mexican back with a neck brace
even that for a Beverly Hills in in man
and then uh I was back there how do you
use my ladder I use the the people that
rent rent in the house was just like old
ass ladder but I just put it up against
the porch climb on the porch get on the
roof right
so I start climbing up the ladder and
then she had like I guess her boyfriend
or the guy that was staying with her was
like a war vet from like I guess the
first invasion of Afghanistan to 2008 or
whatever the [ __ ] it was and uh he had
his [ __ ] arm like his his forearm
muscle blown off so he it looked like a
chicken arm it was it was trippy so I
noticed that but you don't say she who's
gonna get up on the roof see if they got
any openings get the [ __ ] out of here
give you an estimate cuz they had to
give it to the the homeowner so it's not
it was a Friday I was like a Thursday so
it's gonna take some time they can't
make the decision there wasn't gonna be
no check so [ __ ] right real quick so
I thought
and so the war veterans are holding the
bucket ladder I get up on the ladder
dude I start climbing and it's like dude
the guy's little like of the yeah I like
I didn't see how small I was but he's
like five five and I'm time with the
ladder I get up on that ladder I put one
leg up on the porch like the roof on the
porch are you like 14 14 15 feet so and
as soon as I pull up with his leg
this [ __ ] leg I [ __ ] the ladder
underneath me with this leg goes out and
I see that little dude follow is that
like I can't believe this is happening
and then boom I come down but hit the
roof like a cat inside just scratch all
the way down on my nails dog and then I
grab the rain gutter little guys just
trying like I see him like kind of
clutch like trying to catch me and I
just smash this [ __ ]
and then I land the way I landed cuz I
there was a [ __ ] staircase right
there oh we know with no rail just steps
right it was so I landed on a [ __ ]
corner of one of the stairs cross I was
trying in midair to like not land on it
but I couldn't get the twist all the way
so I kind of hit the corner of it and
that's what the [ __ ] bruise happened
to contact the contusion that little
dude I think he was out for like 45
seconds a minute
cuz the lady runs out oh my god you know
so I still got like you know I do a job
and I want to do nothing and when
they're spraying the pan
looking out the window what the [ __ ] is
this guy doing like are you sure you're
gonna be okay
like saying like you suck my dick I'll
be better but whatever but I was like no
because she's off cuz I think that in
her head she's all this [ __ ]
gonna sue us
yeah so she's all like dude like then
here's the 184 spray in the house and
here's 200 bucks if you need anything
else just give me a call but I think
we're gonna be alright I don't even
worry about it and I wasn't even looking
for [ __ ] I was just gonna just do my job
yeah dude and cuz I was talking with
Coco he's on he's serious man he's all
lay down there okay you said call an
ambulance
he's all listen like that's like a
development deal check right there but
you don't even know I'm thinking of if I
do that [ __ ] will be your [ __ ] they'll
catch me in the [ __ ] scam and fried
me but I don't know what the [ __ ] but it
was you know it was my fault I mean I
use that news ladder [ __ ] I should
have known better and [ __ ] you that
would be the last day I ever worked if I
felt you being disability for [ __ ] ah
to you you know Rodrigo I have a crazy
sense in him up only a sense of humours
that I have is I love people saying fall
or ladders I love wall that type of [ __ ]
you know is it is it fair is it funny
like this you see this
oh she's black guy puts a firecracker on
his a the [ __ ] dizzy to me is one of the
funniest things like when I saw this I
[ __ ] like ovid in the middle of Kovac
I lost everything okay so when somebody
thousand if or like I don't want to see
people for like when I saw a Ralphie God
rest his soul fall on Gardner I don't
want a Ralphie to fall but I'm also a
comedian I got when I got played in my
art people laugh in private okay you
know I was telling people last week I
was comparing when you go out to Lou
you know what when you go out and do the
things that we saw on footage last week
the kind of hate that you have to have
in your heart you have to have a certain
age take an old man or do it's just
something that us three don't understand
right but I had that hate at one time I
had that hate because my mother got
taken away by God I watched a show a
movie the other night that I can't
believe it hit me and hard as it did
first of all and all those years of me
doing coke I never even thought about
getting so bad there's a contract of
myself was until I saw the movie ray did
I go maybe it's time the movie ray put
on some the other night I realize it's a
good ass movie dog went at the end with
his mother when he goes back to faces
his mother and his brother comes out he
goes it wasn't your fault
and he breaks down and then she goes you
did you did go out there and you didn't
become a [ __ ] but you let that
[ __ ] poison [ __ ] you
those is a powerful that's crazy he's oh
no and for me right there I was like you
don't want problem I'm out here with
these [ __ ] savages I got the longest
shot I've been on MADtv not that I
wanted to academy award or anything I do
have something going on I do have a good
girlfriend and the last thing I want is
for her to find me dead and the other
last thing I want is for me to face my
dad my mom and my dad what a bloody nose
wherever the [ __ ] they are in heaven and
for them to say what a [ __ ] disgrace
you [ __ ] old deed you know one thing
about me is listen you want to shoot me
you want to take me in a car accident if
the good Lord wants to give me a heart
attack I'll accept those that's all a
part of living I didn't want to die as a
junkie you understand me gentlemen I
didn't want that on my [ __ ] last
thing I'm my [ __ ] death certificate
I don't know we're all gonna die herpes
syphilis something like badass something
a bullet a cop I don't even know what to
tell you we're all gonna die but for me
the choice I wanted was not to have this
associated with drugs
I couldn't especially cocaine so when I
saw that it reinforced me like wow this
is a movie okay this is make-believe but
somebody wrote this this is the mind of
rain when he was telling them yeah so he
told somebody this story that while he
was at the reactor where you go and get
clean the rehab detail the detox
that's the images he was saying yeah
those nights was all sweaty when he is
all sweaty that's what you see you think
back to what is the square root of this
problem you know for me it was my
father's death the death of my mother
the death that's around and all that and
then losing my daughter the way I did
you know I failed as a man so I I'm
saying those were my pains that's what
made me do coke and pick my face until I
[ __ ] bled you know that's what made
me do all these irrational movements you
have to have a bad heart once the heart
comes good look I don't even think about
coke uh-huh well you could put it down
south in front of me you wouldn't bother
me for me I'm not a hypocrite
you can put an arrow and I won't bother
me I mean you put a percocet out of my
eat one you put a happy pill out I might
eat one you put a [ __ ] xanax on I
might eat one but everything else I have
no interest of doing oxycotin I don't
want to write you know like you figure
out what things you want to do I decided
that movie let me know that okay
somebody else is thinking like I am I
don't mind going but I don't want it I
wife to go to the bathroom and seed my
two little fat feet on the [ __ ]
carpet that's not gonna happen I don't
want to leave it come into this office
and find me after a night of snoring all
night that that's not going to happen
you know so it's just weird how you make
all these after years of being clean I
don't even know what we're talking about
you didn't want eyes
man oh no I guarantee anybody who
listens to this that's on pills or booze
or whatever this is the thought that has
to hit you I'm gonna die
but I don't want to die from [ __ ]
boobs I don't want my last [ __ ] thing
to be Joey Diaz died last night
pronounced drunk drunk driving he killed
two people in a [ __ ] car and he
killed himself because I want to have
three drinks that's not the way I want
to go I don't want to go with nothing
related to that [ __ ] I want to go from
the heart attack the kidneys whatever
the [ __ ] the liver infection my [ __ ]
got to be getting something pretty soon
thank God I'm going for a physical this
month like it stick the cam up my ass
again I'm due no I mean these are the
things that we talking about we're
talking about something good I forget
which reef is a good [ __ ] a
little triple axel urban trees 37% that
he posted Jesus Christ Joey did you see
that
I ain't [ __ ] around dawg if we're
gonna go through we're gonna go for it's
Monday the 15th of June [ __ ] it was
edible though remember back in the cuz
we're gonna do that story where I turn
green
you know the Spice guys I want you know
I got this to see the infection like you
gotta remember people had their licenses
for maybe 4 years and I wouldn't get a
license because I had a psychology to
this whole thing
I don't do coke I'm the most boring
person in America I don't drink I don't
go to a bar the only excitement I have
is a right Drive with weed in my car
that's like the wildest thing I do no
cop is never gonna pull a gun on you
they see weed on you you're gonna get a
ticket you might go to jail but that was
the weirdest thing I did so how many how
long do you drive to get a bag of weed
15 minutes that you know when you get
your paycheck on Friday you work Monday
through Friday you can you paycheck on
Friday you're like oh [ __ ] six o'clock
you go cash in at the check cashing
place the liquor store wherever you do
your banking your own bank you know
hey everybody got a different place
liquor store yeah some people do blank a
liquor store yeah well you get that
check and what's the first thing you
think of [ __ ] alright how am I gonna
get [ __ ] we gotta get some weed so then
you drive 15 minutes of Pancho's house
you know all lives matter I'm saying
Pancho Pablo whatever the [ __ ] his name
is we drive over there you pick up $35
worth of weed you put it in your trunk
and you drive back right that's the
scariest thing you're gonna do all that
that's the only illegal thing you do so
my world who I came from Y broke the law
constantly you know I J walked when you
gotta think about it you gotta think
about how many rope you know how many
u-turns do I do a day how many things
but I really do it legally a day we all
do three we all made that u-turn
yeah it's illegal you follow a little
things we all [ __ ] don't put up
blinker on [ __ ] I hate you
[ __ ] what everything I got you
might as well go eat hummus and end our
relationship right now if you don't put
your blinkers on and your relationship
with me right now and that is rude that
is rude you might as well eat hummus and
[ __ ] put on [ __ ] that white singer
than irritates the [ __ ] out of me so
I'll never have to talk to you again but
all those basic things most people don't
do know so I started saying how many
[ __ ] rules do I break a day I'm
talking u-turns I'm talking right on
reds you know I don't give a [ __ ] but
that's just go [ __ ] yourself
if you standing there like a mummy like
a statue of Robert Ely before they take
you down I'm making the right there done
if you're gonna stand there like Robbie
Lee like these traded slaves by yourself
you just stand on the corner with his
little [ __ ] hands robert e lee you
believe they're taking out all these
statues they're taking out everybody
every George Washington he's going
there's alumnus they found that he had
[ __ ] slave teeth they got rich I mean
they're so mad black people they went
back 3,000 [ __ ] years to start
lynching people Columbus I don't know he
might have a problem there
cuz even Matt Cuomo was like where the
Italians like blood on put red paint on
his hands he's got blood on his hands
listen once they [ __ ] change Columbus
Day I knew we [ __ ] up not it I think
they're gonna change Halloween so what -
what Saturday Halloween
Noli yeah look nobody wants your [ __ ]
covert lace fingers I'm like kids
candies oh no no no I want candy for
your kids can then why don't you can't
have to give candy out with a mask on
and gloves on and all that shit's done
this is gonna be a pathetic Halloween I
guarantee they're gonna invent the zoo
virtual boo boo some [ __ ] oh yeah like
if my kids got a stay at home and [ __ ]
eyes them and some guy called me a damn
you kid my kid wants to hang out with
your cousin all right let's do it Sunday
last night 10 o'clock
me and my wife were watching something
Saturday and [ __ ] he texts like a 10
o'clock tell Joey I didn't check with my
wife what will you tell Joey you just
told me Friday why you calling my wife
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and they tell Joey
that we have to go to a zoom party on
Sunday whatever that takes 10 minutes I
want to see a zoom party like I wanna
see [ __ ] rape body I want to see a
good woman get ready come to our
birthday party then you know how come my
zoom birthday party not a million
[ __ ] years late people 11 people
online yet they somebody told me I spent
wine on my [ __ ] computer during a
zoom happy hour you should
electro for you I hope you got
electrocuted right this you gonna be
their tip and wine and [ __ ] how old the
week people they're too much there too
probably we love goofy technology the
more goofy technology they give a
tic-tac what the [ __ ] is that
oh that's stupid with your daughter
[ __ ] no got to screen like kind of like
you know better version of Instagram for
videos I see the dances but it is that
isn't one funny thing about this is some
people like are losing their minds about
what like not being like able to see
their friends and stuff I'm fine I'm
losing a little bit but for the most
part I'm good I don't need to zoom
anybody or see anybody just gotta go get
air like once a day you have to go
outside yeah got a move yeah listen what
I was about
III don't what so is this went down I
broke down my prison day and I saw what
I did in the parameters of offense
within a day and how you make it work so
Studio City where this area where I live
isn't was my fence I just got a big
offense everything was closed how long
so that's prison
I'm not walking into 7-eleven ever since
Colvard started I was already losing
patience to 7-eleven has germ central
right there the last year and a half
I've been losing patience in life and we
tended going they're gonna give $1 I'm
homeless dude yeah the worst homeless
people available to mankind they're
always in a wheelchair they always got
[ __ ] on on this [ __ ] just walking in
there is Colvin what about the night
some [ __ ] lady attack me and leave
because we pulled up and I didn't turn
lights off and she started yelling at me
at least I put the i-beams on your a
dollar do and even back
was [ __ ] she wasn't dick it was just a
me this is a prison so I broke it down
to the same [ __ ] thing I'm gonna
parameter what can I do before I thought
you went to prison I rode a bike I
played a lot of basketball but guess
what happened wrong with the prison you
got to become a runner
you know when Colvard started and the
next day everybody was Rocky
nobody was jogging before by Wednesday
everybody was Rocky head bad thought
that a bunch of kids chasing a white
dude I never seen somebody become rocky
in their [ __ ] life when you go to
prison you become Rocky okay you either
could become Rocky for an hour you could
sit yourself for an hour see become rap
you for an hour
what's the other option you got in
prison religion everybody goes they
everybody just this guy just let his
kids on fire he walks into prison he
finds Jesus really that easy you've been
walking around for ten years going to
parties and Jesus was never there
now you go to the depths of depths and
Jesus is automatically there and these
[ __ ] walk around with the Bible
they start quoting the [ __ ] the Bible
either oh they get the Bible and they
start quoting the [ __ ] then some of your
tapes man yeah he let his kids on fire
sold them by the pieces you know like
these these are horrible people and
often they find Jesus in [ __ ] jail
and you expect my guy like me to believe
it I'll sure enough I would watch all
those guys how convenient
I would watch all those guys on the day
they were gonna get checked out like all
those guys were Bible beaters you watch
them and you watch them at the gate
thinking that a lot of check and once
they get that check you see them walking
down and like 50 yards away from the
gate you see the Bible go up in the air
like it's over it's over I'm going back
to raping [ __ ] you know what the
Tenth Amendment says
tenth commandment thou shalt not rape
midgets I'm back I'm done I don't give a
Frenchman's [ __ ] you know you just you
find and this is all jokey in the ship
when I got in there I just found the
ways to avoid my room and then there was
ways that it was inevitable so I would
watch TV a certain time I would do this
a certain time but my job was to this
time was different I have a child father
in prison with my kid so I gotta help my
kids draw and I gotta beat ins on a book
and you know this is it but it also has
made me reform love with everybody in
the house we got really tied to all this
it's quality all time is quality time
now listen today she started camp and I
am [ __ ] a lot hey you know I'm
excited I can't wait to go home and see
what the reporters today she starts camp
and kickboxing this is a big thing today
let's see what the house brings tonight
it's a little camp you know for two or
three weeks until they figure out what
the other [ __ ] camps open and
tomorrow night tonight we'll see what's
going on at four o'clock when I get home
cuz she has to come home and can't take
a shower and go to the kick box and then
take another shower so we gotta run the
code bit you know science you can't
breathe that all day with protesta Brett
allergic to allergy Brett you know cuz
these kids like allergic to peanuts you
know they're getting kovat ah she
doesn't mean that she's gonna [ __ ]
die you're gonna die so it's just I'm
ready for that [ __ ] you know it's just a
mental thing for the last seriously man
I I really appreciate you being my
friend for a long [ __ ] timing we go
back to the Felipe's room with Willy
yeah man tortillas tortillas how good
was that [ __ ] burger
ah the green burrito the green that's
pork that [ __ ] was off the [ __ ] that was
part of my contract
[Laughter]
we breed over cuddly bear always took
care of me yeah I was 400 pounds I will
either huge dinner at the house and that
gig would startle 8:30 so you get that a
corner of the nine Edwin would be
smoking joints outside we go out the
back door with the little manager he
leave the door open for you and us and
we've smoked a joint by the by the
hospital yeah that's a Beverly Hospital
it EE Hospital weed smoke joints out
there
he ain't of us out there guys $40 in the
burrito you guys are an ongoing what are
you talking about for a burrito that was
as good as it got that and you saw how
many people Willie me you Jeff Garcia I
mean there was ten of us ten of us some
fly fly head head head who started
showing up yeah he's open mikes yeah
you've seen him on Facebook a lot it was
a Peter now our head you know there was
just so many [ __ ] pops you know
Armando
I mean people out every night you saw
these girlfriend alfrid you saw these
[ __ ] people
you know Chapel and that's what I was
trying to explain to Cassius I missed
that camaraderie
listen I wish I made the money Kevin har
that you know why cuz I think I just
bring my friends and take over a floor
like I bring over six comics I've been
on the podcast and that's what I would
do if I if I was selling arene out are
you [ __ ] kidding me I bring all my
friends it just be a week a goof take
over the first class light on fire we go
back the gun you know you ever see the
[ __ ] documentary from Motley Crue on
Netflix yeah he's like they're the
craziest [ __ ] of all time they
show
what's his name running naked behind the
[ __ ] the security guard is chasing
and he runs out and they run in and
steal his coke this [ __ ] you know that's
what the road was for yeah but don't
mean it wasn't to do road like what I
was doing now going in my room in the
web and staying up till 1:00 it's you
know but you don't have the energy no
more in my mind if you pay that money to
come see me I want to be the best of you
I can't do a show hungover
I have to be as I get [ __ ] all over
they go on a fishing trip during the day
yeah come back I got third-degree
sunburn last week guys I had Sun
poisoning sunset Wednesday night goddamn
you stayed out too long no I did what I
do all the time this is why I was gonna
bring this up today California you're
not gonna believe what's happened in the
last 90 days so whenever you tell me
we're going to the beach I give you calm
and you go come to Riverside I got a
beautiful beach for you and your family
I'll go beautiful I'm gonna make tacos
up I'll be done in an hour first thing I
do is I take a shower when I come out of
the shower I drop my hair everything get
ready but then I put a layer of lumber
[ __ ] ten on me like a layer of number
50 I don't know one of my wife an SPF
whatever so it sits underneath and I air
dry I let it get into my pores and then
as soon as I get to the beach I do
another layer and then 25 minutes in
when that first be the sweat comes out
that means it's time for another layer
then you go in the ocean and you come on
you do another layer and then whenever
lay area file I did that all day guess
what happened on California nobody's
driving so pollution is gone so the Sun
is that much stronger
it's like beam in Colorado when you live
in Colorado there's no extra layer you
go out for ten minutes you come back you
look like [ __ ] you know John Jones
you're like what the [ __ ] I was white
when I left the house I came back I
forget American because ya know you're
in you know whatever thousand feet
elevation and the Sun you're closer to
the Sun and
sunset you burn I go to the beach once a
week of my wife I do the same process
every week I've never gotten this sizzle
I got out of that [ __ ] car when I got
out of that car I was done I couldn't
even move
I don't think I haven't take one of
those wash with showers the water's cold
he said put the Jews in there first one
of those wash with Shou is [ __ ] out
there appeal invented crowd they say in
the Japanese did does it that cold
that's not I can take a shower I put the
water on super cold I took a shower and
about an hour later dog I started
getting dizzy I thought I was gonna puke
I washed my hands I stuck my finger down
my throat then I started getting chills
and I had to put a hooded sweatshirt on
and sit on my couch and just shake the
house was 70 degrees I was just shaking
from being cold because my body therm
dermis so the last two days I may be
[ __ ] up your body temperature the last
three days I've been able to leave the
house I'll leave the house with shirts
on and I can't come in contact direct
contact with the Sun because the Sun
goes right through a t-shirt
burns the Sun you have no [ __ ] idea
what I thought wrong every week during
this coronavirus I've had a different
adventure I just don't give it that much
[ __ ] for two weeks I was in a pissing
spree
once the corners all fear well now for
all that water I lost my water weight I
was pissing every 10 minutes I never
seen them like that my life I even call
the doctor I can't stop [ __ ] pissing
who I do I was pissing I pissed myself I
almost crashed my car - one day cuz I
got hot let him put the brake on the car
kept rolling and I'd my dick out and
also because I got to pull the skin back
it's it's been a hell of a coronavirus
Jeff ladies and gentlemen I whacked off
one night and then why you do you know
sometimes you whack off in your chair I
worked off of my chair and I held the
tip because I'm in a circumcise I hold
the tip for a little while and it'll all
fill up her it turns it's like a Cobra
it looks like a Cobra dick and I must
have been high
sleep and I woke up with ghoul in my
pants you know it's been an adventure
people nobody [ __ ] nobody had a good
time then cooker on a virus you found
out all your weaknesses if you're a
loser you found out I did I found that I
was a straight-up [ __ ] loser over
this virus you know but I'm happy you
made it too late dog tell you let's that
it's a Monday morning [ __ ] podcast
just trying to spread some love and keep
your final are you I don't want to yell
nobody you know sadly again the [ __ ]
another UFC last week so wait a second I
just watched them burn a gas station or
Wendy's in Atlanta they just burnt it
and you want me to watch 19 fights in
the UFC ain't happening I didn't watch a
minute of those fights [ __ ] Saturday
no I watched fights all [ __ ] week
riots yelling screaming and we I want
someone watch more fights that telev
poison your [ __ ] mind I don't know
what he's thinking there's something to
watch oh my god everybody's fighting I
could not I don't want to watch fights
it's it's ridiculous it's like dog this
is all we're talking about right now can
you imagine being on a flight to Abu
Dhabi right now for that Island 20-hour
flight or wherever to be are you [ __ ]
good are they [ __ ] crazy
even on a private plane I don't want to
do that are you [ __ ] crazy I gotta go
all the way to Abu Dhabi to get into a
fist fight that's you trying to [ __ ] it
down me at this point in my life i cuban
if you're UFC fighter right now a lot of
mark find out of them are like will not
fight nothing now where's the money yeah
there wasn't scary it's just [ __ ]
scary
and if the fight must go on [ __ ] and
if people really know the root of all
this they would go wow we didn't know
that well let him find out all the time
they have to fight they have you know
they have to keep that name brand alive
ESPN don't lift the rock so as it's a
looks at story getting embarrassing you
know it's starting to get embarrassing I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't pay attention
to it I want some money on the car man
sweet believe unless we got him rent the
main card you want to keep seeing fine
that's a bar move to bed and then not
even by the main command the boy [ __ ]
yeah how are you no I don't want to
watch all that fighting the prelim card
was enough
there's people fight all over the
[ __ ] country right now I should be
watching fighting even football I don't
really want to see let's get some
baseball going baseball is nice people
are nice when they play baseball right
everyone someway getting there with a
baseball the Japanese come out from the
back
oh they're gonna matter number one
people were mad at Houston remember that
when that was a thing for cheating that
would I'm still no I don't know no it's
over you know why they get mad at that
and that pissed me off that's a real
smack in the face to get caught like
that know that they didn't Pete Rose is
somewhere right now getting therapy cuz
they won't let him does he put a bet on
a bunch of games today I disagree with
the Pete Rose thing you know what man he
[ __ ] up he [ __ ] up granny's player
or the greatest top five players having
to live five positions five positions
always got the party started Charlie
hustle man always get the party started
he don't he's nothing like one of the
Baseball Hall of Fame
I grew up idolizing that dude too
similar analyze Bruce Lee I loved Pete
Rose that's how you do whatever you do
in life you do like Pete Rose
wasn't he a coach on a team and then one
day he just said [ __ ] it he went inside
played for the team and in the games I
could play a coach yeah he was like [ __ ]
he was also betting from the [ __ ] bad
no let me ask you a question
is he the first guy never do love the
last I [ __ ] know look what we're
finding out now
that's worse than gambling on baseball
all those guys involved on that and my
world should get kicked out of baseball
but we didn't give it the media
attention that it deserved yeah wait a
second this isn't cheating in Las Vegas
this isn't she first of all cheating is
cheating okay
get that straight cheating is cheating
but you cheated in baseball like we got
a turnabout we gonna start the season
and these three guys are still arguing
all Joey corner and I'm not mad at
Houston everybody was involved
let me tell you something there was a
lot more teams that were named that was
involved yeah I'm in the Red Sox we lost
our manager because of what happened
when he was with used to and I'm sure it
happened to all the time they just
revealed the Yankees but everybody says
it's a common common Pratt thing it's
just like they've just brought it out
the box you have to assume it it just
got a little out of control yeah because
they were using like electronic in the
dugout that more sophisticated it was a
little bit more sophisticated yeah
stupid or banging a trash can hotel nah
dead I would have looked into that
little deep but I would have suspended
the players for this year do you think
as far as the Piero's you think they're
gonna reinstate him one day the way it
looks now Pete well this is an example
and listen I'm a human being I don't
know how to react to things all the time
I make mistakes we all do as human
beings one thing I will tell you is he
reacted kind of weird I think he's
talking [ __ ] and it's kind of personal
like it's like me leaving here golly
this is your podcast office from now on
Joey's done you do what you want except
don't [ __ ] and I have Pete Rose on
please hold on to that decision forever
that's where I think the Pete Rose thing
is like behind closed doors Pete a
little bit more you got blacklisted and
they just said leave him the [ __ ] on the
[ __ ] Antonio sabato jr. is working
construction in Florida because of Trump
a couple Trump tweets or some [ __ ]
really like that's that's crazy fast
your life changes it has been right now
it is
the last three and a half weeks four
weeks it has been the worst time to be
on social media Adam oh yeah I don't
care what you say to me or yourself and
it's pathetic what's going on on social
media right now
you know it's pathetic and even when I
try to go on there to lighten things up
I guess I can screen that I get screamed
at which is the first time ever in ten
years of social media people bisect
words I have never been bisecting them
before so guess what
stay on social media first of all when
you go on there and read this [ __ ] you
know it's just a lunge a bunch are
educated people putting up [ __ ] and now
you get even more [ __ ] Drona Ian's in
the [ __ ] television so why are we
watching this [ __ ] this is worse than
what you're doing now why are you
watching this [ __ ] I go online sometime
just to check in you know maybe
somebody's sent me like it on the
weekends very seldom do I go on it
very seldom if Terry goes to bed early
on Saturday I'll go on there and go on
messenger and check all my messenger I
have 14 15 messages
I'll get high I'll go through them but
as far as stay on them on Saturday and
Sunday especially now more than ever I
avoid it I think I avoided after
Wednesday because there's no wedding
right now nobody wants to everybody
wants to [ __ ] there's always three
people are attacking yeah I move to get
attacked once a week fat man your man
and your daughter you know all that type
of [ __ ] it's been higher than ever
don't everybody wants to [ __ ] yell at
somebody right now and I think that's
why I understand the riots that's why I
understand the rage yeah this isn't just
this was a riot thing you know this is a
race thing that's also along with six
weeks of being at home yeah
I'm waiting on an unemployment check
waiting on a sub minimum whatever
sublingual check whatever the [ __ ] they
call unemployment all that [ __ ] oh you
know your business going out of business
because you gotta pay unemployment you
know a lot of people were in pain
already
you know how would you feel if you were
the [ __ ] owner of that shoe store
last week Sunday night and you're
watching your Melrose store get kicked
in and people running out with your
shoes our buddy Dante China it's that
story got this one decimated really yeah
they took everything yeah on Melrose my
heart goes out to Dante Chang what's the
name of this store
flashback flashbacks old flashbacks
opens up please support it Dante Chang
is a great [ __ ] kid I'm very sorry
about that how would you feel if you're
at home you just hugged your kids empty
you know you sit down there looting on
Melrose and you're like ah that's a
little far from my choice but they're
getting closer and closer now you gotta
make a choice you got a machine-gun
ar-15 and run down and stay in front of
your business I would just Dorian style
and do get for [ __ ] people with you
to stand there with you who's really
gonna want to stand with you to possibly
shoot somebody that's another thing are
they gonna mean a lot of factors
involved so you know this has been a
wild [ __ ] ride for a lot of people
man but again it's Monday you bad
[ __ ] Pablo's nuts it's gonna be
a [ __ ] good week California's not
gonna be in hot as last week last week
was brutal here but this week [ __ ]
you're gonna hear birds chirping again
it's gonna be nice and cool in the
morning my little bike rides I got my
little by 25 bust other picture I've
incognito
you know calendar with you on the bike
bro somebody busted me the other day who
was at the light I was at the light and
I had a crossed that way and they were
like the third car and I'm sitting there
and I forgot to pull my mask up after I
drank water
it's despites like ten yards where I
usually stop to get Warlick as a shade
and I see what time it is and I finished
my last loop
nobody's gonna see me on this bike ride
only to see I've gone on to traffic head
on nobody's beeped nothing and the eye
dam on the corner all creepy is [ __ ]
and I'm about to cross the street and I
hear some guy go oh well Joey is that
you want a bike and I'm like no no this
little alley and I wasn't down the alley
I could tell he was making a left gonna
look for me [ __ ] that [ __ ] he
was Parliament antifa he wasn't gonna
find uncle Joey I'm done dog I don't
want nobody to see me on that bike it's
embarrassing oh my god my wife took a
picture of me on the bike not good
people would pay having that [ __ ]
circus and no your attraction of the
night uncle Joey on a bike and there I
am my little red helmet like a [ __ ] come
out with my little rock mountain bike
dog it's a [ __ ] doesn't have a basket
no I haven't crossed the line that much
yet once I put once you put the basket
on you gotta put condoms in there cause
you're getting [ __ ] me as Vaseline on
there that means you're giving up
[ __ ] in different portals like when
you see this how the city has set up
different bike stands that's what you do
now you just go to different bike stands
and get [ __ ] in the ass they got a
basket but me you should ride one of
those bikes you know as soon you said
that's all I could think of like what am
I waiting for it's right there on the
platter like Jersey Mike's no right
there by the why would you go to Jersey
mice with all those people even though
still don't touch those germs you know
what it's better where you know where
nobody has touched a bite well Marie oh
they do have my dad for that liquor
store they haven't moved
I'll just go buy a helmet I asked that
lady one day I went to buy a lotto
ticket I wonder if the tires okay
yeah I want to see what Hummer you gonna
wear a size eight thousand extra man you
got a Nazi helmet and make a complete go
to Sherman Oaks on Saturday drive around
you will not see element although citic
Jews walk in the temple I defy those
[ __ ] in yellow black lives
matter I bet they have one of the army
surplus store dad go for it this
that's not a fit either that or [ __ ]
boom boom and his football helmets in
the 8th grade somebody who's got a big
nugget like mine oh you got to see it's
just a little shell on my head I'm still
gonna die this don't do nothing it's
just I was like a Chinese guy with a gun
oh you know those will try Japanese
Vietnamese hats that's what it looked
like it just covers me perfectly look at
me look at my face I was burnt so that's
the part it's missing what's that
No yeah the Sun [ __ ] but once you
pull us I leave the house at like 10:00
to 7:00 sometimes you call me so early
recently is not a car and the street you
just popped the left listen as I pop the
left I feel this [ __ ] warmth from the
Sun already hitting you well it just
hits you right off the bat and it feels
like I haven't feels like cotton and you
know I just keep riding and I try not to
stop you know your mouth gets dry with
that [ __ ] mask on though you're
walking around like Ali Baba in the
[ __ ] desert I mean you're [ __ ]
tried though I finished ten of water
before I even get back home it's gone
you dry up with that [ __ ] mask quick
and that's the thing that I want you
you've throat to dry during this cuz
that's on these [ __ ] Ebola germs
Sultan Arabs could sit in there so you
have to keep hydrated hydrated is the
biggest [ __ ] weakest word ever well
that was a county to drink water for 12
hours
do you whether they were at the beach my
mom my wife wouldn't stop we have to get
mercy out
she must be dehydrated by now she's in
the ocean she's Cuban she's sucking the
water into the [ __ ] little holes I
guarantee it
we even yelled you thirsty she's like no
why would she be thirsty only white
people get thirsty at the beach with
Cubans we thought 12 hours well a glass
[ __ ] on the water
12 hours but you ride your bike without
a mask that [ __ ] gets dry quick bro dry
your breathing you're huffing you're
popping your horn up
it's a [ __ ] nightmare but it's gotten
me through this [ __ ] that so we all
found something some people found
quaaludes found dicks in the air some
people found [ __ ] calming drugs the
bicycle saved my life so who gives a
[ __ ] Rodrigo what he got on the books
what are your plans for the rest of the
year
well [ __ ] you know we're gonna start
going out on the road again July that's
July 17th of the 19th in uh at the
Houston improv was Phillipe it so we'll
see what the [ __ ] happens after that
he's got a pretty full schedule yeah
those are the the the couple uh
the date gave me so I guess it's gonna
be the start off date trip I'm proud of
you it's good to see you 20 years now
yeah man 20 years I've been seeing your
face you never gave up you're still
doing your podcast you still do your
little room in Riverside yeah we got
that uh we got that going on we're gonna
bring it back you know details and [ __ ]
with the whole [ __ ] code yeah a
beautiful little I Fork Center making it
happen you're a comic no matter where
the [ __ ] you are
we do a little acting classes right yeah
the best we can we do the best we can
This Is It this is what it's all about
it's just swinging from the [ __ ]
fences and Seamon a ball wins who gives
a [ __ ] cuz suck my dick I'm happy you
got the way can they follow you at
instagram at Rodrigo Torres calm Rodrigo
towards junior and then at Twitter as
well I Rodrigo Torres jr. and what's up
fool podcast yeah what's up full podcast
we got over 290 episodes with Felipe
Esparza and Martin Rizzo's on the gig
now and I use on the podcast yeah yeah
and I do a podcast in Spanish with
Martin Rizzo
those podcasters at North they okay we
got 15 episodes available in my own
podcast I'm a podcaster though yeah man
that's all we got going so we just
possible the same [ __ ] that we always
did you know with this whole [ __ ]
that happened adapted had you know got
my own little trade back for a minute
and you know just doing it just you know
I'm trying to me know make some decimals
keep your head above water not everybody
gets unemployment all that [ __ ] so
you gotta just and you got a um you've
been some right now if you had
doing anything exactly exactly did but
uh but uh yeah man just uh just keep on
truckin though I'm proud of you messing
up you found time hell yeah for the
church oh it's happening now
[ __ ] on a Monday morning real
quick let me talk to you about a few
things number one
Irvine is scheduled for the 2015 20 cent
Brea Irvine improv and Brea is scheduled
for the 25th to the 27th of June I do
not know what's going on yet they said
they confirmed Monday that it might only
be a hundred tickets so that's all I
have I think they yanked July 31st from
Las Vegas I think August 1st is done in
San Diego and I think I got Utah snow on
the second and fourth but I'm also
waiting on The Sopranos shoot so
everything is up in the air guys I'm not
going on any other dates
another void do we find out what this is
I will be having a residency and Bram
starting in July every other Tuesday you
know again there'll be no meeting reits
so if you come in to meet and greet
we'll let you know when they start I
don't want to take your money I'm gonna
keep the tickets of $20 on Brad
I'm working out I'm just trying to get a
new hour and trying to feel out the
audience and how I'm gonna feel on stage
and if I should leave to move forward
with this or that's it move on you know
that's that's what the plan is right now
hopefully we get the book out by
February hopefully you get the movie out
by September 12 then we'll see how we
feel then but right now is not the time
to be making travel plans to Europe in
September I have a funny feeling they
gonna be [ __ ] putting the squash on
all that [ __ ] whether you're slinging
dhikr you're at home you always want
your balls to be comfortable you always
want to be comfortable and what you're
wearing should be tip-top Magoo this
might not have just misses it might not
be this summer you had mine I get it
but you know what chain you're young the
pants can change your [ __ ] mindset
you [ __ ] I've been telling you
from the beginning you got up in the
morning you take a shower you get
dressed you change your clothes it's all
over
gotta go with me undies that is the way
to go I've been working with them
they've been working with me for years
not because I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] because I
love what they do I got me undies on
right now I got a whole drawer full of
them they're the best underwear going
you go to jujitsu you want to keep your
balls clean you're going to the girls
house to get your little Pole to sup
afterward where's some me undies
you can roll for an hour they have a
material it's mold or [ __ ] tremendous
it makes you both feel like they're
getting cradled by a little midgets
hands you you will see a little midgets
hand is nice and thick well anyway it's
just a fantasy no matter what they're
made from micro mold doll fabric it's
actually made from trees and they come
in all shapes and sizes from extra small
the 4x all bodies welcome even fat
[ __ ] like me they got a great
offer for the church family for any
first-time purchases they're gonna give
you 15% off and free shipping listen me
undies is the only underwear for me now
you gotta get the balls to try you're
gonna be tweeting me going Joey why
haven't you told me about these before
and they all have 100% satisfaction
guarantee they gave you 15% off go to me
on these dot-com slash Joey I'm gonna
give you 15% off your first pair free
shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee go to me undies
doc calm slash Joey
I want to thank me undies doc toms last
Joey I want to thank CB d lion comm
slash Church I want to thank my brother
Rodrigo Torres Janna and [ __ ] up yeah
yeah what's up full bottle gas
yeah man podcast and the other many
Latin projects he has I want to thank
the [ __ ] Jew the [ __ ] but
most importantly sorry I had a pubic
hair might rope I want to thank you for
the animals for listening and for being
part of the church family eight well not
stars we're not Dave Chappelle we're
just trying to give you them but heart a
little bit of laughter on them one day
[ __ ] afternoon
all right stay black have a good week
and we'll see you Wednesday tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo kick this [ __ ]
meal Lili Whelan
[Music]